За оцінками експертів, через пандемію коронавірусу
в Україну повернулися кількасот тисяч заробітчан.
Хтось із них втратив роботу, а хтось злякався,
що влада закриє кордони не тільки для іноземців, але й для власних громадян.
Чимало є й тих, хто планував поїхати на заробІтки, але не встиг виїхати до пандемії.
Нині багато хто з них намагається потрапити на роботу за кордон власним ходом -
попри те, що карантин досі не скасовано.
Збираюся їхати на роботу,
але спрва у тому, що зараз це дуже складно їхати туди, тому що треба проходити обсервацію,
дорога дорога дуже, щоб добратися до Польщі.
Майже в три рази все дорожче.
Продуктів там треба купити, щоб харчуватися на обсервації.
За житло треба заплатити на обсервації.
Тобто фінансово дуже затратно, але все одно збираємося їхати, тому що в Україні
взагалі немає ніякої роботи для людей нашого віку.
Оксана Фурман і її чоловік Сергій минулого року вже їздили на заробітки в сусідню Польщу.
Працювали, зокрема, пакувальниками на заводі з виробництва телевізорів.имсч
Заробляли по 800 доларів на місяць.
Оксана каже, про такі гроші у рідному Хмельницькому можна лише мріяти.
Сидимо ці два місяці вдома - це просто жах! Це сидіти дуже важко.
Це дуже важко, і всі тільки надіємося на те, що виїдемо за будь-яку ціну.
Будь-яку ціну.
Тільки щоб потрапити на роботу.
Польські робочі візи Оксана й Сергій встигли оформити на початку березня -
до закриття візових центрів.
Для них це - перепустка за кордон.
Поїхати на заробІтки прямо зараз можуть лише ті, хто вже має необхідні документи,
каже Тетяна Бугакова, директорка однієї з компаній,
що займається працевлаштуванням, переважно у Польщі.
Виїхати як турист за біометричним паспортом,
знайти вакансію і вже на місці оформити дозвіл на роботу, як дехто робив до пандемії,
тепер не вийде.
Зараз мають право виїхати на роботу за кордон люди, у яких є
тимчасова посвідка на проживання за кордоном.
Другий варіант - це відкрита робоча віза.
Третій варіант трошки складніший, але також можливий:
це людина, у якої є біометричний паспорт
і так зване "освядченіє", це такий документ
на кшталт дозволу на працю, на підставі якого укладається трудова угода з роботодавцем.
Необхідність мати чинний дозвіл на роботу - не єдине, що стоїть на шляху заробітчан.
У Польщі вони мають пройти двотижневу самоізоляцію.
Деякі роботодавці оплачують проживання на карантині, деякі - ні.
Якщо додати витрати на їжу, самоізоляція коштуватиме щонайменше 800 злотих на двох,
підрахувала Оксана Фурман та її чоловік.
Це - більше 5000 гривень.
Але хоч подружжя і платитиме за проживання у хостелі, з пошуком житла їм пообіцяли допомогти.
А от як доїхати - треба думати самим.
Шукатиму зараз якихось перевізників, буду добиратись.
Це тільки до кордону?
До кордону. А з кордону треба з іншими перевізниками домовлятись.
Так не їдуть, щоб прямо з України до Польщі.
Рух автобусів через кордон наразі заборонений рішенням уряду.
Крім того, у березні влада заборонила і пасажирські перевезення Україною.
Утім, в інтернеті можна знайти чимало оголошень з пропозицією трансферу
до українсько-польського кордону імпровізованими маршрутками.
Охочих забирають зокрема з Київського вокзалу.
Щоправда, везуть такі перевізники лише до пункту пропуску на українському боці.
Щоб потрапити у Польщу, доведеться "підсісти" до однієї з автівок, які перетинають кордон.
Коштує це, за словами одного з перевізників, понад 2000 гривень.
А у Польщі доведеться знову шукати інший транспорт, щоб добратися до місця самоізоляції.
На думку Тетяни Бугакової, директорки однієї з компаній з міжнародного працевлаштування,
цю проблему допомогли б вирішити чартерні рейси.
Роботодавці погоджуються сплатити цей чартер власним коштом,
тобто транспортувати своїх робітників, які на підставі їхніх документів отримали візу.
Вони зацікавлені, щоб ці люди потрапили до них на роботу.
І для людини це буде набагато зручніше, тому що не потрібно буде два-три дні витрачати на дорогу.
І це все буде досить організовано, комфортно.
Тим часом, український уряд змінив свою риторику
щодо виїзду українських заробітчан за кордон.
Ще наприкінці квітня міністр закордонних справ України Дмитро Кулеба заявляв:
всі зусилля уряду спрямовані на повернення українців з-за кордону -
тож, організовувати чартери для вивезення заробітчан було б нелогічно.
А вже через два тижні віцепрем'єрміністр з євроінтеграції Вадим Пристайко
в інтерв'ю Deutsche Welle пообіцяв не тільки авіаційні,
а навіть автомобільні і залізничні рейси для сезонних робітників.
Питання відновлення праці наших людей, які звикли працювати за кордоном,
залежить в першу чергу від роботодавців у тих країнах, де вони звикли працювати.
Уряд України не обмежує - ми лише намагаємося придати цьому руху якусь координацію.
Все більше і більше рейсів відновлюється -
і авіаційні, і ми зараз працюємо над автомобільними і залізничними рейсами.
Наразі з Києва вже відбулися спецрейси до деяких країн -
зокрема у Фінляндію, Великобританію, Австрію і Німеччину.
Утім, поки що це лише поодинокі спецрейси,
які не можуть задовольнити потреб десятків тисяч заробітчан і їхніх роботодавців.